invité cette semaine de preuves par 3
henri guaino candidat à la
présidentielle au nom du gaullisme
d'engagement ou un positionnement que
vous n'êtes pas d'ailleurs le seul à
afficher dans cette compétition qui
s'ouvre ce sera d'ailleurs la première
question de l'émission et hervé guinaud
bonsoir gaulliste vous avez dit
gaulliste c'est à dire
deuxième question que vous posera
ensuite mis kms de public sénat
pourquoi en voulez-vous autant aux juges
vous voulez revenir notamment sur leur
indépendance garantie par la
constitution vous aurez l'occasion de
vous expliquer tout à l'heure enfin
troisième question sur la primaire un
mode de désignation peu à votre goût 1
mais vous vous lancez quand même droite
gauche avec françois hollande désormais
qu'ils acceptent cette procédure comme
le président sortant est ce que la
primaire est désormais un passage obligé
vous répondrez à déborah claude de l'
agence france-presse partenaires de
notre rendez vous donc de preuves par 3
d'abord première question donc gaulliste
vous avez dit gaulliste art je vais vous
soumettre plusieurs noms si vous êtes
d'accord pour 2017
michèle alliot marie marine le pen
nicolas dupont aignan françois hollande
qui vient de se rendre à colombey les
deux églises un premier président
socialiste faire ce déplacement sur la
tombe du général tous invoquent donc les
mânes de de gaulle est ce qu'il ya dans
la liste dans le lot la des usurpateurs
selon vous écouter parce que chacun
chacun reconnaîtra ce qu'il y a 2 de
sincère ou non d'incongru ou non dans la
référence des uns et des autres ou au
gaullisme que le président de la
république aille se recueillir sur la
tombe du du général de gaulle je ne suis
pas dupe mais enfin c'est un hommage
institutionnel qui me paraît la moindre
des choses
compte tenu des services éminents que le
général de gaulle a rendu à la france
pour le reste moi je suis pas je suis
pas le porter de la vraie croix de
lorraine j'ai ma conception du gaullisme
c'est à dire tout le monde peut s'en
revendiquent les noms mais tout le monde
soit on était de tout du christ de
bouddha
de napoléon de 14 mois je ne me retrouve
pas forcément dans les leçons que chacun
de ceux qui se réclament du général de
gaulle tir de de cette histoire car car
le gaullisme c'est une histoire c'est
pas une doctrine c'est pas un catéchisme
c'est une histoire qui commence en gros
le 18 juin qui s'achève avec la mort du
avec la mort du général de gaulle
d'ailleurs le final 2 à part ces
ouvrages sur l'armée dans
l'entre-deux-guerres n'a écrit que des
mémoires
alors nicolas dupont-aignan estime que
son mouvement debout la france incarne
le mieux le gaullisme c'est ce qu'il dit
nous le disaient en tous les cas l'autre
semaine
l'appelant d'ailleurs à le rejoindre
jean pierre chevènement arnaud
montebourg et et vouant l'écoutent et
puis henri guaino et puis beaucoup
d'autres je prends tout ce qui vole
défendre un patriotisme républicain qui
redresse nos entreprises et qui
relocalisent un million d'emplois qui
rétablit la sécurité en mettant les
boyaux en prison qui apprend à lire et à
écrire à nos enfants qui remet l'hôpital
public sur les rails qui renégocie tous
les accords européens et qui rend à la
france le contrôle de ses frontières
et qu'est-ce qu'ils aident un programme
de salut public que je propose et je le
propose avec mon caractère mes soutiens
de dans un esprit de rassemblement
gaulliste et avec un esprit de
rassemblement gaulliste alors vous
seriez prêt à le rejoindre à moi je ne
suis prêt aujourd'hui à rejoindre
personne j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
nicolas dupont aignan nous venons de la
même famille politique
partageons certain nombre d'idées en
commun d'autres nous avons des
divergences sur d'autres sur d'autres
points
mais je ne suis aujourd'hui prêt à
rejoindre personnes aujourd'hui je suis
décidé à défendre moi même mes idées mes
convictions l'idée que je me fais de mon
pays et des leçon que je tire de vin une
fois de cette aventure elle était le
codis alors on va en parler tout au long
de cette émission un nouvelle candidate
pour 2017 qui affiche des les couleurs
du gaullisme en corse et michèle alliot
marie est ce que vient là vous disputer
le titre que lui répondrais mais un
panier pas titre a disputé moi je vous
explique comment voyez vous en arrivez
dans le jeu je la vois et d'enfermement
légitime
je ne comprends pas ce débat sur le
nombre de candidats ya des élections il
ya des candidats
après chacun s'exprimera et nous verrons
comment s'opère la rencontre avec les
français des uns et des autres
l'expression c'est une rencontre comme
toute élection d'ailleurs elle se fait
one ne se fait pas moi je viens tels que
je suis avec les mots que j'ai envie
d'utiliser pour exprimer mes idées peau
pour la france je pense que je ne
pouvais pas rester les bras croisés ni
devant la situation du pays de l'europe
et du monde ni devant ce que j'entends
dans deux propositions jusque je vois
comme comportement en plus dans votre
corps mais oui sinon eux aussi m'ont
quand même satisfait aujourd'hui vous ne
seriez pas candidat à la primaire alors
vous avez salué la décision
institutionnelle de françois hollande de
se rendre à colombey-les-deux-églises
saluer je trouve pas ça normal vous
voulez pas critiquer un arrêt mais alors
qu'est ce que vous dites non j'ai dit je
n'étais pas naïfs ya surtout des
arrières pensées politiciennes mais moi
je lui veut y voir que l'hommage du
président a quand même que voyez-vous
dans les déplacements alors répété de
florian philippot le numéro 2 du front
national il fait régulièrement de mai
mais est ce que vous critiquez également
marine le pen qui encore abondamment
cité de gaulle ce week-end à vienne le
dernier week-end en vantant l'europe des
nations l'europe à la carte et en
réclamant des référendums est-ce que là
il ya une usurpation du côté de
l'extrême droite selon vous ragez
toujours trouvé un peu un peu curieux
que le front national cherche
à capter l'héritage du général de gaulle
j'ai plutôt tendance à penser hélas que
comme la la droite républicaine a fait
ou à laisser disparaître le gaullisme de
l'échiquier politique bien et les thèmes
de la nation de l'état d'art public des
frontières de l'indépendance de la
souveraineté ont été ont été pris par
d'autres
quitte à ce que ceux qui les prennent
parfois les caricatures évidemment si
vous demandez si sud accord sur le
référendum l'europe des nations
oui c'est d'accord tout dépend comment
on en parle tout dépend ce qu'on veut en
faire encore une fois je veux pas passer
mon temps à me positionner par rapport à
madame le pen il par rapport à tel ou
tel
je veux expliquer ce que moi je souhaite
alors bien sinon je deviens un
commentateur de toutes les candidatures
et de tous les partis aujourd'hui je ne
reconnais pas le front national comme
l'héritier du mouvement gaulliste je
pense que je ne suis pas le seul
mais s'il s'agit de de militer pour plus
de référendum et pour plus d'europe des
nations
et bien c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
avons des objectifs communs voilà c'est
à propos des risques avec madame le pen
avec un tas de gens à droite à gauche
nam au centre à propos de référendums
est-ce qu'ils peuvent aller selon vous
contre l'autorité de l'état
parfois je pense à au référendum pour ou
contre l'aéroport notre message et parce
que ce n'est pas un référendum ça c'est
une livre sublimation non c'est pas un
référendum non au référendum c'est la
nation en prenant sur un sujet là c'est
un c'est une consultation dont on a
d'ailleurs du mal à voir comment on peut
définir le corps électoral
je sais bien que conseil d'état a validé
le valider cette consultation la loire
atlantique se rappelle cette
consultation n'a aucune valeur légale
n'impose rien au gouvernement ni au
parlement
allez c'est une consultation après
pourquoi tel département impôts
personnels département est incluse dans
le
dans le corps électoral pourquoi elle ne
l'est pas où s'arrêtent les conséquences
de salé les l'affût les conséquences que
peuvent avoir les décisions qui seront
prises figure sur l'aéroport parce
personne n'est capable de la jolie avant
le mari viennent à voir la question du
référendum ça n'est pas la question qui
est posée par cette consultation à quai
lors du référendum c'est de savoir si
sur des sujets majeurs le peuple
français a le droit de dire lui même ce
qu'il veut d'exprimer lui-même son
opinion de décider pour lui même et par
lui-même et non par la voix de ses
représentants pour ce pour quoi vous
plaidez mais correspond sur la crise à
dublin pour que tout soit passé de passe
partout je plaide pour que d'un certain
nombre de sujets soient soumis à
différentes
restons sur la consultation donc
appelons le comme ça ce référendum sur
notre élan puisque le premier ministre
est intervenu sur le sujet tout à
l'heure on écoute le gouvernement
tiendra compte bien sûr du résultat de
la consultation
si le nom l'emportent le projet sera
abandonné
si le oui l'emporté dimanche le projet
sera engagée je veux également rappelé
que quel que soit le résultat les
personnes qui occupent illégalement des
propriétés devront partir l'état de
droit s'applique à à notre dame des
landes comme partout ailleurs dans le
pays
voilà donc vous avez réponse à votre
interrogation à lavau critique là le
résultat de la consultation s'imposera
ou non non non non ne s'imposera pas le
gouvernement a décidé de suivre les
résultats de la consultation aucune
règle constitutionnelle ou légale de
quelque nature que ce soit n'oblige le
gouvernement il se sentirait vous
contestez donc non je conteste rien du
tout gouvernement a décidé ce qu'est ce
que le gouvernement ne pouvait pas
décider
il n'arrivait pas à décider forcément il
fallait régler des divergences entre les
ministres du gouvernement
et comme le gouvernement n'est pas
gouverné comme le président ne préside
pas comme personne ne voulait trancher
les conflits entre ceux qui à
l'intérieur du gouvernement sont
d'accord et ceux qui sont contre et bien
le gouvernement a décidé de se défausser
sur une consultation
bon voilà c'est très bien c'est le choix
du gouvernement ça ça va grandir encore
un peu plus hautes autorités de l'état
et vous pensez oui justement mais là il
nous le dit le chef de l'état l'état de
droit va s'impliquer se vêtant vous
croyez pas mais pas qu'il serait temps
que l'état de droit s'applique
il serait temps que l'état fasse preuve
d'autorité vis-à-vis de ceux qui viole
tous les jours la loi les analystes en
l'occurrence et et puis si encore
c'était des manifestants pacifiques mais
c'est ce sont très souvent des
manifestants violents d' autorité de
l'état encore henri guaino le mot
gaulliste chienlit revient beaucoup dans
la bouche de certains de vos amis en ce
moment vous l'avez constaté qui a raison
dans le nouveau bras de fer est pas
encore réglé là à l'heure où on parle
entre le gouvernement et les syndicats
sur cette fameuse manifestation de jeudi
à paris les syndicats refusent
catégoriquement une manifestation
statique alors d'apprenants lequel
d'abord de la manifestation statique une
manifestation statique c'est plus
dangereux qu'une manifestante qu'un
défilé
voilà c'est moi j'ai fait l'expérience
de la manifestation cette tique
lors du débat sur le mariage pour tous
on a le gouvernement qui attendait moins
de monde a fait interdite aux
manifestants de défiler il les a il leur
interdit de traverser la place de
l'étoile
il a parqué sur l'avenue de la grande
armée et je peux vous dire que la
poussée de la foule qui s'entassent de
plus en plus est extrêmement dangereuse
au demeurant d'ailleurs si des violences
devaient éclater au mieux de cette foule
ça serait bien pire qu'au milieu d'un
défilé donc voilà je ne crois pas du
tout à la supériorité en matière de
sécurité delà de la manifestation
statique
voilà pour le premier point le deuxième
c'est que le gouvernement est
responsable de l'ordre public mais ne
s'est pas étalé pas les syndicats je ne
comprends pas comment dans une
démocratie on peut interdire une
manifestation de salariés ou de
syndicats cela vous l'avez entendu les
arguments les connais vous avez
maintenant il m'arrivait la dernière
manifestation oui messieurs sont de
sécurité des biens et des personnes et
bien sûr des soviets attaché il ya une
violence autour de la thématique des
forces de l'ordre mais mais la fatigue
des forces de l'ordre ne peut pas
justifier qu'on interdise des
manifestations qui sont l'expression
même de la démocratie
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec la cgt
suis pas non plus d'accord avec le medef
sur la la nuit avec le gouvernement mais
en fer contre le maire il faut aimer ou
et je suis contraint de la loi danoise
depuis le début mais enfin c
il est quand même extravagant de penser
qu'un gouvernement peut faire cela alors
le gouvernement d'ailleurs s'est mis
dans une situation impossible et il
affaiblir une fois encore l'autorité de
l'état parce que imaginer
et que les syndicats décident de braver
l'interdît quand même de manifester à
lille va-t-il se passer
que va-t-on faire que peut-on faire mais
quand quand le gouvernement prend une
décision il doit être certain de pouvoir
la mettre en oeuvre
sinon il perd la face et il affaiblit
l'autorité de l'état aux réformes pas
seulement 7 du gouvernement ces aides de
l'état en tant qu'institution et la haye
le pays ne peut pas continuer de
fonctionner avec un état qui s'affaiblit
tous les jours pendant que fera le
gouvernement si les syndicats décident
de manifester quand même bon c'est une
vraie question était recherché il va
faire charger les syndicalistes par les
crs violemment et vous allez vous pensez
que ces images à la télévision vont
améliorer le climat social du pays où
son climat politique non le gouvernement
joue avec le feu
le gouvernement joue avec autorité de
l'état le gouvernement a mis tout le
monde dans un dans une impasse
il savait très bien que la cgt était
affaibli il a essayé de là il a essayé
de l'affaiblir encore ça me rappelle en
95 un gouvernement cette fois ci de
droite qui voulait tuer faux bond à la
pâte ufo mais en revanche on a on a
transformé un septennat en semestre
cette crise a été un tel désordre
à la fin je veux parler d'alain juppé je
précise je parle de 95 alain juppé moi
oui
le gouvernement de l'époque allemand de
l'époque voulait tuer fois un
gouvernement c'est pas là pour tuer un
syndicat c'est pas là pour affaiblir un
syndicat c'est là pour que le pays
fonctionne c'est là pour discuter pourra
négocier pour essayer de trouver comment
faire et c'est difficile mais vous êtes
quand même si gaulliste social vous êtes
pour des réformes quand même mais vous
économiques et sociaux mais pas
n'importe qu'elle veut dire quoi cette
espèce de light motiv sur la réforme la
réforme la réforme on vous dit jamais 2
quelles réformes il s'agit on vous met
brusquement sur la table un texte
puisque vous êtes pour la réforme des re
voila de réformes alors accepté là et
non peut être pour la réforme mais pas
pour celle-là d'accord alors pour vous
vu comment ça a été fait oui on a pas
d'issue aux mains discuté avec personne
on a mis ce texte qui était ni fait ni à
faire se lever et corrigé avec des
négociations avec ces derniers le ccja
c'est du marchandage on a fait le
gouvernement a donné droit aux
revendications de la cfdt
et il a ignoré les autres et ils
savaient très bien il savait très bien
qu'en six pros non de cette façon il
allait provoquer des blocages bien mais
c'est pas ce n'est pas tout c'est non
seulement si on en croit les enquêtes
même s'il faut pas gouverner que les
enquêtes d'opinion on est parti quand
même à 80% de français dans les enquêtes
con
dans 65 à 70% à droite c'est vous dire
comment ce projet vous donner des
chiffres plus au début on mangeait loi
c'est à dire c'était bien c'était
c'était c'était bien par laurie mais non
c'est je trouve que c'est assez
important parce que c'est c'est
représentatif de l'art de gouverner
on ne peut pas gouverner de cette
manière on ne peut pas gouverner non
plus un pays qui est aujourd'hui
tétanisés par le chômage de masse
tétanisés par la peur de l'avenir comme
on gouverne un pays au milieu des trente
glorieuses
quand on gouverne un pays dans cet état
on prend des précautions on sait que la
société fragile et on donne pas le
sentiment aux gens qui ont un emploi que
c'est de leur faute si une partie de la
population n'a pas d'enfant vous parlez
surtout à vos amis politiques de droite
1 et par la commission interne
oui mais c'est les gouvernements
libéraux vous conter ses j'avais une
question pour marc daou j'ai trouvé
qu'elle ait autant de voir mes amis
d'hier je voterai ce projet de loi mais
il va pas assez loin en début et dire
aujourd'hui je ne voterai pas parce
qu'alors il va vraiment pas assez loin
de là j'avais des sentiments vaille et
qu'on va sortir la france de l'ornière
dans laquelle elle et ne payant plus les
heures supplémentaires un peu plus cher
à ceux qui travaillent le plus et qui
ont besoin de ce pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire pour pouvoir faire leurs
fins de mois et bien vraiment c'est ce
qu'on regarde pas l'économie de la même
façon et vous et moi on va pas refaire
oui on va pas refaire tout le débat sur
la loterie mais là il s'agit de mesures
qui seraient avalisée par des
référendums alric
oui je rappelle aussi l'invention du
gouvernement non seulement n'a pas la
majorité depuis mis la même pas à
majorité au parlement
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à défendre
49,3 mein kampf 3 c'est un outil normal
constitutionnel pour pour gouverner
simplement il se trouve que ça signifie
qu'il n'a pas la majorité au parlement
il n'a pas sa propre majorité vous
pouvez pas même pas opposés à ceux qui
protestent le fait le parlement à voter
henri guaino pour un gaulliste il pour
vous le gaullisme je résume
c'est la capacité d'une nation à dire
non je résume c'est vrai que les
britanniques hendaye le gaullisme aussi
parce que quelqu'un m'a posé la question
il n'ya pas longtemps
le gaullisme c'est pas non plus de
diviser le pays d'accord alors l'a68
savez comment ça se termine monsieur
bros sur wii par les accords de grenelle
il faut savoir quand quand tout est
bloqué
quand ya pas de solution il faut que le
gouvernement sache s'asseoir à la table
de négociation négocié de la crise
grenelle bah oui ou alors lors où le
gouvernement retire son projet ou bien
on recommence à zéro on discute c'est un
vrai sujet et ça peut pas être traité
comme le gouvernement l'a fait la
capacité de gouverner comme sa nation de
dire non est ce que vous espérez que les
britanniques qui diront nous on
référendum sur le break site je ne
savais rien du tout je ne suis pas
brittany non mais je dois voir les
craintes je constate qu'on donne le
droit au peuple britannique de dire oui
ou de dire non c'est déjà un progrès je
constate aussi que on utilise toujours
les mêmes arguments envers les
britanniques ont monza utilisé envers
les les français jadis toujours les
mêmes arguments et arguments c'est
l'europe ou le chaos où vous dirigez
vous en faire écouter un autre fait vous
allez le découvrir suivez vous
intégrerez l'homme là je vous rappelle
que voter non ça va voter oui à l'europe
il convoque aussi des les grands hommes
lui churchill dans mon bureau je suis
assis à quelques mètres du cabinet
winston churchill a décidé en mai 1942
se battre contre hitler probablement la
meilleure et la plus importante des
décisions jamais fait dans notre pays il
ne voulait pas être seul il voulait se
battre avec les français les polonais et
les autres il n'y a pas abandonné il n'a
pas laissé tomber la démocratie
européenne
il n'a pas laissé tomber la liberté en
europe nous voulons nous battre pour ces
choses
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas gagner
nous ne pouvons pas nous battre si nous
ne sommes pas dans la pièce
vous ne pouvez pas gagner un match de
foot si vous n'êtes pas sur le terrain
voilà pourquoi il faut être hennezel en
avait qu'un en comparaison absolument
lamentable c'est vraiment si un anti à
un euro sceptiques avaient fait la même
même genre de comparaison on l'aurait
voué aux gémonies pardonnez moi ça n'a
strictement rien à voir avec churchill
en 1940 face à hitler
mais alors rien du temps alors je
voulais vous parler d'aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy a rencontré angela
merkel et elle est d'accord c'est lui
qui le rapport pour que paris et berlin
élabore un nouveau traité européen qui
donne un centime aux européens que nous
entendu sur ce qu'ils disent a précisé
nicolas sarkozy est ce que ça vous
paraît de bonne augure
un nouveau traité envisagé par paris à
berlin oui mais d'abord je ne pense pas
que tu allais jiang est là mais d'abord
je ne pense pas que paris et berlin puis
sa seule avancée à l'europe sa son
avenir ils sont fabriqués son destin
deuxièmement je ne crois pas beaucoup
hélas que roux trouvera la solution
refaisant un nouveau traité on peut
faire des améliorations importantes
supprimer la commission reprennent par
exemple changé peut-être le mode de
désignation du parlement européen il ya
des choses à faire mais enfin la vérité
que nous n'arriverons pas pas plus que
lorsqu'on a voulu faire un traité
simplifié n'y sommes arrivés pour on a
fini à lisbonne avec un traité compliqué
nous n'y arriverons à mon avis pas comme
ça nous y arriverons en dise en étant
capable de dire non chaque fois que les
intérêts vitaux de la france sont en jeu
et en obligeant nos partenaires à bouger
à chaque fois comme la fin du général de
gaulle avec la chaise vide au milieu des
années 60 et la politique agricole
commune
il vaut mieux être il vaut mieux prendre
le risque de créer des crises limitée
pour éviter une crise générale et petit
à petit de cette façon changer
complètement cette europe qui ne peut
plus continuer comme ça et si on fait un
grand prêtèrent l'été allemand on va
refaire on va se refaire l'isthme risque
de refaire lisbonne et de ne rien
résoudre du tout pas l'âme on sentira
bien voilà vous avez répondu à cette
proposition esquissé aujourd'hui par
angela merkel avec nicolas sarkozy
arrière deuxième partie de preuve par
trois rien ne l'évité aussi si vous
voulez pardonnez moi de faire toujours
des grandes déclarations sur la nation
sur l'indépendance la souveraineté et
puis après se précipiter se précipiter à
berlin pour faire allégeance aux
allemands le couple franco-allemand
c'est très important il faut le
préserver mais ça demande un effort de
part et d'autre c'est à dire peut-être
un effort des français et un effort
aussi des allemands mal à chaque pas il
n'ya pas d'allégeance la france n'a pas
à faire d'allégeance l'allemagne pas
plus qu'aux états unis c'est oubliera
d'être un pays souverain et elle fait
valoir son point de vue et ses intérêts
ou bien ne les plus polémiques et des
abbesses de public sénat nous rejoint
maintenant pour vous poser cette
question pourquoi est ce que vous en
voulez tant au juge henri guaino voulait
revenir dans leur indépendance je vous
entends 18 avril
vous estimez ils ne doivent pas se
syndiquer aussi évoqué la réaction vive
de la présidente de l'union syndicale
des magistrats
virginie duval à moi je vous vois déjà
soufflé que vient de rencontrer
géraldine bavois l'eau les magistrats
doivent être indépendants dans leur
nomination dans leur carrière ils
doivent être responsables également
certes mais en tout cas ils doivent pas
dépendre du gouvernement c'est pas au
gouvernement de décider dans des cas
précis dans des dents des affaires
précise les poursuites ou pas je crois
que monsieur guaino il a un contentieux
ancien avec avec les magistrats avec un
magistrat et donc du coup ils se il
n'arrive pas à se défaire de ce2 ce2 ce
conflit ancien et il n'arrive pas à se
rappeler qui est quand même élu de la
république en forme et conserver celle
de samsung est notoire de répondre à ça
près tout de suite et v2
d'abord le syndicaliste dans la
magistrature c'est précisément pour que
la magistrature soit un peu plus
indépendante parce que l'indépendance
est pas juste l'indépendance à vis du
pouvoir politique indépendant c'est
d'abord l'indépendance vis-à-vis de
soi-même vis-à-vis de saison de ses
engagements vis-à-vis de son idéologie
vis-à-vis de ses choix politiques qui
nous est donc les religieux voilà donc
le syndicalisme est en train de détruire
de détruire l'objectivité l'impartialité
de la magistrature
ça suffit je pense que les syndics le
syndicalisme n'a rien à faire dans la
magistrate donc vous président vous
interdis envergure étage
moi je ne dors je ne soutiendrai pas un
candidat à la présidentielle si ce n'est
pas moi je ne suis pas un candidat qu'il
ne proposera pas une réforme importante
de la justice la justice aujourd'hui est
un élément du désordre du chaos des
institutions là pour premièrement
surtout le manque de moyens dit on un
nom mais ça je suis d'accord il faut des
moyens physiques mais attendez c'est pas
là on parle pas des moyens les moyens
nous renvoie à la politique budgétaire à
la politique économique
vous voulez une usine que ça sorte que
dolan mais je passe par quoi la priorité
leur là il ya plusieurs d'abord on ne
peut pas donner de tels pouvoirs à des
gens qui n'ont de compte à rendre à
personne
un principe de responsabilité doit être
établi instaurée et compta grave ou 6,6
à la justice à la police fallait faire
la police dont vous pouvez créer une
autorité indépendante où il n'ya pas de
magistrats ou très peu voilà cdma gens
peuvent pas continuer
à se juger eux mêmes à se contrôler
eux-mêmes s'ils n'ont procédé gêne
encore mais sinon on a pour l'instant
c'est plutôt beaucoup de citoyens qui
doit être protégé parfois dit la
séparation des pouvoirs entre le poly
dans des injustices non mais là et ça
c'est interdit en principe de
responsabilité donc ça c'est normal
qu'on vous donne le droit de détruire
des vies sans jamais avoir de comptes à
rendre à personne ça il est normal que
ça soit le seul corps ou quelqu'un qui
commet une erreur quelqu'un qui détruit
la vie de quelqu'un puisse continuer à
être promu c'est et à continuer à juger
les autres non ça c'est pas possible
le syndicalisme je vous espérez toujours
penser il faut savoir quand même que les
militants syndicaux sont des magistrats
qui ensuite reviennent dans la
magistrature dans les formations de
jugement
moi je je ne peux pas comprendre ses
engagements politiques
un avocat pour moi dit engagement
politique ce sont des sottises peut-être
non non il ya les deux villes en
politique et l'engagement corporates et
jusque dans les deux cas dans les deux
cas c'est parfaitement inacceptable mais
politique
un avocat l'autre jour se rend à la cour
d'assises de metz le local de l'union
syndicale des magistrats
non madame et secrétaire général se
situe en face de la delà de la cour
d'assises afin de la chambre assystem
est sur le sol sur la porte il ya un
dessin humoristique dans un palais de
justice à sa guise de certains noms
c'est très intéressant et des sauces
dessins humoristiques ya nicolas sarkozy
qui est en train de tomber en glissant
sur des petits ronds et écrit il a
glissé sur les petits pois faisant
référence à ce que nicolas sarkozy avait
pu dire non voix raison de la
magistrature
mais c'était trop les magistrats n'ont
rien à voir palais de justice dans un
palais de justice par des magistrats qui
vont revenir dans des dans des formats
de rouler à céder aux syndicats non non
je n'en veux pas que principe de la deux
du syndicat ni dans la magistrature
et bien on proposera l'interdiction et
les français trancheront
voici quoi par référendum sur la justice
mais je pense qu'il faut une grande
réforme de 6,6 en référendum sur la
justice en ce moment mais la question
c'est c'est intéressant comme l'est
jamais remplacer les juges la tutelle
pardon excusez moi mais est ce que est
ce que les journalistes ont un petit peu
travaillé la question du référendum
le référendum ça n'est jamais
est ce que vous voulez sur un projet de
loi oui c'est un projet de loi que
gaspard le jeu le quart le quart le cas
anglais il est il est tout à fait il est
tout à fait à part c'est ça veut dire
'est-ce que vous rejetez tous les
traités on sort très bien là c'est une
simple question sans texte mais là plus
qu'en général le référendum c'est un
texte
est-ce que vous approuvez la
constitution de la vème république
est-ce que vous approuvez des accords
des propositions et c'est toujours ça à
un référendum
ça ça vous demande de vous prononcer sur
un projet de loi qui peut être un projet
de loi constitutionnelle ou en projet de
loi non constitutionnelle
voilà qui soit un projet de loi
ordinaire bon donc vous aurez si on le
fait un projet de réforme de la
magistrature et les gens seront amenés à
dire oui ou non à cette réforme
un jeune s'est vraiment c'est tout ça
par les banderoles un débat donc la
responsabilité
le problème des centristes le problème
tant des dépendances
elle est aujourd'hui elle est vraiment à
les menacer un dépenses justice et fo
troisième et troisièmement la nomination
il faut aller voir comment ça se passe
ailleurs mais les nominations aux états
unis elles sont faites par le
gouvernement américain pour les juges
fédéraux
les juges fédéraux la plupart des juges
et des tatous sont élus et les autres
sont nommés par le pouvoir peut vraiment
avec en grande-bretagne pays delà des
mots clés re-so de la démocratie une
commission indépendante le goût des
nominés une commission indépendante
nommée allemand c'est pareil c'est nommé
par la mise mais pas émise la justice
d'enfants qui est un système très
intéressant
une commission indépendante qui fait des
propositions au ministre de la justice
le ministre la justice est libre de les
accepter ou pas signer refus ça revient
devant la commission qui refait d'autres
proposent un coeur bon alors ok on a
compris et c'est toujours
enfin la légitimité du pouvoir politique
elle est entière
c'est dans une démocratie s'est-il la
souveraineté du peuple qui s'exerce soit
par la voie de son porte donc en
l'occurrence du gouvernement et du
parlement soient pas en parlerez ferme a
compris mais je ne relancerait pas sur
la notion et non l'indépendance mais non
mais parce que l'indépendance dont il
est question vous faites référence
interne à la constitution
me remettre en cause l'indépendance de
la justice mais elle n'est pas
indépendante
quand elle est là juste à quel point le
pouvoir de nomination il est toujours
politique toujours politique dans une
démocratie ou alors on est plus en
démocratie balisé mois alors c'est pas
attendez j'ai pas j'ai pas fini c'est un
sujet trop important
non mais c'est quand il y en a d'autres
oui mais celui là celui là il est il et
il est absolument essentiel il ya le
problème de la formation des juges vous
pouvez pas considérer non plus qu'un
juge qui réussit encore 22 ans 1 et par
droit divin le protecteur des libertés
vraiment pardon je ne me sens pas
protégés dans la liberté par la justice
telle qu'elle fonctionne aujourd'hui
vous ne savez pas protéger la non pas du
tout dans c'est pas du tout et quand
j'entends le débat sur le sur le sur
l'état d'urgence
je trouve ça assez cocasse à venir à la
limite je me sens plus protégés par le
référé liberté du juge administratif que
parle que par beaucoup de magistrats de
l'ordre judiciaire dont il ya peut-être
quelque chose qui va pas et je suis pas
le seul
je pense que beaucoup de français
considèrent que ça ne va pas très bien
bon on a le problème du juge
d'instruction par un juge d'instruction
ils doivent supprimer il doit je suis
pour la suppression du juge
d'instruction mais on aura un débat et
puis on proposera en français le juge
d'instruction il doit il doit instruire
à charge et à décharge
c'est peut-être parfaitement surhumain
puisque beaucoup de juges soit soumise à
des gens soient plus souvent à charge
ça peut pas continuer comme ça il faut
un système où les équilibres soit
rétabli très bien on a compris c'est par
ces cas là ça n'est pas possible non je
finis à la politique pénale
oui mais oui mais là c'est pas
l'indépendance non la politique pénale
c'est pas l'indépendance de la justice
la politique pénale c'est le
gouvernement et l'exécutif
c'est le peuple qui choisit quelle
politique il veut sévère ou pas sévère
je reprend l'histoire de deux de
l'incrimination des terroristes
bon et bien dans la politique pénale moi
je veux pardon c'est le sait le
procureur est pas le juge du siège qui a
l'opportunité des poursuites
mais le jeu et le procureur il
représente la société et le gouvernement
donc le
il est tout à fait normal qu'on donne
des instructions pourvu que ces
instructions elle soit public pourvu que
le celui qui les donne en assume
publiquement et devant l'opinion la
responsabilité moi je trouve que on
devrait incriminer les terroristes sur
la base de l article iv sens du code du
code pénal sur intelligence avec une
puissance et une puissance étrangère à
une organisation une entreprise
étrangère qui est juste ici prépare ça
c'est pas le temps de réformer c'est
juste qu'il faut rétablir il va falloir
maintenant dire quelle est la place de
chacun la place de chacun c'est ça ne
peut pas consister à ce que la justice
se gère elle-même décide elle même de la
politique pénale décident elles-mêmes
qu'elles nous peut ou non coopérer avec
la police avec la gendarmerie avec
l'exécutif ça n'est pas possible qu'elle
peut pas continuer on a compris on a
signalé des procureurs qui refuse qu'ils
refusent de coopérer alors le préfet a
été policier allez faites le tour de
france allait voir les préfets et les
policiers mais ça peut pas marcher comme
un temps de questions j'ai une question
sur les moyens dans le désert français
sale ça joue aussi mal
une petite question sur les moyens d'
injustice le manque de moyens par
exemple on appris aujourd'hui qu'au
tribunal de bobigny des peines étaient
prescrites faute de personnel mais ça
c'est inacceptable mais ça c'est le
fruit non pas d'une politique judiciaire
ça c'est le c'est le fruit d'une
politique économique d'une politique
budgétaire
voilà c'est ça fait des années et des
années des décennies quand congères la
fidh la dépense publique par le
rationnement le rationnement le plus
stupide au lieu de rationaliser la
dépense on la rationne le résultat c'est
que ont détruit le système de santé ont
détruit si on détruit là on détruit le
système judiciaire ont détruit la police
on a pas mal détruit l'armée maintenant
on se rappelle se rappelle qu'on en a
besoin
enfin c'est mémé ça ça nous entraîne sur
la politique économique est ce qu'on va
continuer avec les politiques comptables
et politiques d'austérité pour faire
plaisir à bruxelles et un certain nombre
de gens qui confondent la compagnie va
régler sur les institutions avec la
prochaine question de maîtrise mais ça
c'est essentiel d'augmenter moyens
racines mais le sujet nous renvoie à la
question la politique économique et de
l'arrêt de la politique budget rien de
bien sûr sur les questions là cette fois
sur les institutions de trois questions
très ciblée faut-il
notamment réduire le nombre de
parlementaires on peut réduire le nombre
de parlementaires
la limite c'est qu'à partir du monde les
parlementaires sont élus dans des
circonscriptions
il faut qu'elle soit d'une taille tels
que le parlementaire puisse
effectivement parcourir sa
circonscription
ce qu'il faut revenir sur la loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats oui moi je suis
totalement opposé au non cumul des
mandats sa nourriture les mêmes lignes
que nicolas sarkozy a beaucoup de gens
mais je vais vous expliquer à nicolas
sarkozy je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
non ça plaît pas à beaucoup de gens
qu'on refuse donc le fil des mandats
mais mais je pense que c'est une erreur
fondamentale dans un moment où la nation
et menacées de dislocation
on est en train de dresser par tous les
moyens le local contre le nacional et
nationale contre le local
c'est une erreur historique si tu nous
alors on fait l'impasse sur la nation
dit c'est fini en liquide mais si on
veut pas mais moi je ne veux pas moi je
pense que la nation elle a une très
grande importance à une grande
importance sur la démocratie une grenade
pour faire un pas de relégation pour la
5ème république mans sur la nation la
cie vous opposer le local et national
vous voulez contribuer attendez on parle
de vous parler du pendant les 15 euros
ce matin
vous me parler du cumul des mandats bon
toutou la démagogie consiste à dire il
faut pas cumuler mais je vous rappelle
que le fossé entre les français la
politique était moins grand quand il
avait aucune règle de non-cumul 1 dans
les années 60 ça se passait beaucoup
mieux mais c'est aujourd'hui c'est en
tout cas c'est le pire moment vous allez
opposé le local et le national
et si vous faites ça vous contribuez un
peu plus encore la dislocation de la
nation et ce sera catastrophique
ou alors sur le sentiment profond sur le
divorce avec l'opinion entre l'opinion
et puis les politiques et les âges de la
succion c'est simple il faut écouter
vème république août et à écouter henri
guaino la vie du constitutionnaliste
jean philippe derosier
plus globalement essayé d'introduire
plus de démocratie dans la constitution
notamment pour montrer que le politique
refait confiance ou fait confiance aux
citoyens
filmant le citoyen n'a plus confiance
dans la politique ce qui se traduit par
une
d'abstention plus en plus élevés ou des
votes qui vont vers les extrêmes et ce
citoyen ne faisant plus confiance à la
politique il faut que le politique
refasse confiance aux citoyens en les
montrant que ce dernier peut avoir la
parole peut proposer des lois
d'initiative populaire peut demander
l'abrogation de certaines dispositions
législatives
autant de modifications qui pourraient
être introduites dans notre constitution
c'est quoi l'avenir pour les
institutions à ce qu'aujourd'hui est ce
que c'est la grande coalition droite
gauche droite extrême droite pourquoi
parler ans mais aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans un sauna une chaîne dans une fin de
cycle politique
heureusement que les institutions de la
vème république ou plutôt ce qu'il en
reste après qu'on les ait tellement
abîmée j'ai appris qu'on les a tellement
abîmé jeudi dans le quinquennat de
legault le gouvernement des juges
oui moi je moi je souhaite enfin je
pense que les institutions de la vème
imputait lequel était après la réforme
de 60 de l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel
constituer un bon équilibre est très
triste très fidèle à ce qu'elle a
construit ce qu'a été la construction de
l'état et de la nation en france était
aujourd'hui heureusement qu'il en reste
quelque chose moi même parce que
imaginez ce que serait l'état du pays si
nous n'avions même plus les institutions
qui permettent de le gouverner dans le
désordre dans lequel nous sommes plongés
bon heureusement même avec un président
qui n'est pas président qui ne fait pas
le président le payer quand même
et quand même à peu près gouvernement
mal mais il a à peu près gouverner
enlevé enlever des institutions il reste
plus rien donc moi je suis pour qu'on
revienne à l'esprit initial des
institutions de la vème république vous
dire que les primaires n'ont pas leur
place
j'écoutais ce que ce que disait de
constitutionnalistes mais le honnêtement
le vrai problème c'est qu'il ya bien
c'est pas craint pas d'horizontalité de
participation non c'est qu'il est au
contraire plus de verticalité plus plus
d'autorité le problème il n'est pas
toujours pas résoudre tous les problèmes
par les institutions il ya aussi le fait
qu il ya le problème du personnel
politique mais on est à la fin d'un
cycle c'est à dire emmené dans ce moment
dans ce moment particulier où
précisément
parti incapables qui sentent le moins
indispensable à la démocratie mais
incapable de résoudre des problèmes
auxquels ils sont confrontés
ce repli sur eux-mêmes se replie sur les
combinaisons partisane sur les
correctement voilà c'est ça c'est des
apparentements de la quatrième
république vous aviez travaillé avec
emmanuel macron mais j'ai pas envie très
remaniée les maquereaux on est d'accord
sur rien ou presque s'est passé c'est
moi je veux bien être avec des gens que
tu as eu d'accord vous savez plutôt
d'accord a travaillé avec avec
chevènement
maintenant je suis tout à fait prêt
traditionnellement vous n'avez pas un
problème marion maréchal-le pen mais non
je suis pas très fan coalition n'a rien
mais ça le pen tu prêt je les dis un
jour je suis prêt à faire un rapport à
ses quelque 29 octobre 2015 oui j'ai dit
s'il s'agit de faire un rapport suis
prêt à faire un rapport au parlement je
suis prêt en ferrain avait travaillé au
parlement avec monsieur chassaigne le
président du groupe communiste avec les
centristes avec les socialistes mais ça
c'est pas ça c'est pas su ça c'est le
travail parlementaire bon on peut
réfléchir en ce sens assez mais je
participerai pas un gouvernement du
front national ni à une coalition du
front avec le front national c'est non
et d'ailleurs je ne supporterais pas que
ma famille politique décide de faire ce
genre de coalition c'est pas avec les et
coalitions de partis c'est pas avec les
manoeuvres d'appareil sais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on arrivera à résoudre le
problème de la crise politique la crise
politique
elle et elle les dents dans la société
la crise politique aller dans les
politiques qui ont été conduites la
crise politique est les dents dans cette
espèce de folie qui nous a conduits
depuis des décennies alors par privé les
gouvernements de tous moyens de
gouverner
alors un jour au nom des marchés l'autre
jour au nom de l'europe un jour c'est
l'argent jour c'est la bhl c'est des
droits de l'homme jour c'est la justice
qui doit gouverner le monde entier enfin
voila on les gouvernements n'ont plus
les moyens de gouverner
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est les
crises sont devant les crises majeures
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés c'est
que les gens n'ont pas d'autres
évidemment comme toujours
non non non non pas d'autres ressources
que de se retourner vers la politique
qui n'est jamais que l'expression de la
volonté humaine l'histoire et la
politique aujourd'hui ne répondent pas
elle ne répond pas par défaillance
morale intellectuelle elle ne répond pas
aussi parce que nous avons organisé un
la paralysie de la politique alors il ya
plus de recours contre contre contre
tous qui menacent d'y intervenir les
hoquets à l'orgue et gergy remercie mes
kms sont va passer à la troisième partie
d'une mission maintenant avec deborah
clos de la sp qui nous rejoint droite
gauche avec françois hollande maintenant
qu'ils acceptent la procédure de la
primaire comme président sortant la
primaire est elle désormais à un passage
obligé et vous allez donc répondre à
déborah dans un instant d'abord on va
écouter jean christophe cambadélis lors
de son annonce surprise du week end
nous sommes obligés de faire une
primaire dans l'urgence pas de notre
fait mais nous ferons tout pour qu'elle
soit représentative et qu'elles
permettent de clarifier et de désigner
notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais je là vous dès
maintenant
il n'y aura pas autant de votants que la
dernière fois je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait l'obtenir
bonsoir deborah bonsoir les primaires à
notre invité en règle des primaires vous
en parliez brièvement tout à l'heure
c'est un correspond pas à la vème
république elle marche sur la tête la
vème république avec un président
sortant qui sont de ceux là on marche
sur la tête tout court c'est la
cinquième république et marche et tout
le monde marche sur la tête
d'abord les primaires elles ont un
inconvénient elle les enferme le
candidat à la présidentielle et le futur
président dans un camp c'est camp contre
camp alors première remarque les cas on
regroupe de moins en moins de gens c'est
à dire le qui regroupe aujourd'hui la
majorité des français c'est ccc de ne
pas appartenir 1 qu'en sais tu sais il
ya la droite la gauche qui se réduisent
de plus en plus et puis à tous ceux qui
en a qui ne veulent plus de cette
histoire alors qu'il soit ils vont dans
les partis protestataires soit quand
vous regardez là l'envolée des gens qui
déclarent que leur nom aucune proximité
partisane c'est considérable on voit
d'ailleurs sauf aux présidentielles on
voit d'ailleurs où on vote pour une
personne on voit d'ailleurs dans les
législatives ne sait pas les autres de
l'énormité de la
de l'abstention le fait que le président
sortant se livrent à ce jeu de la
première première et c'est la première
c'est la première remarque cette
histoire de caen est extraordinairement
nocives puisque le président de la
république aspire et doite aspire à
devenir l'homme de la nation et donc là
dans l'état actuel des choses dès les
primaires c'est une op à une
confiscation de l'élection
présidentielle par les camps c'est à
dire en réalité pas parce qu'ils d
animer une structure les partis à droite
et à gauche mais bien sûr droite et à
gauche d'ailleurs ça a donné un résultat
merveilleux là on a fait des primaires à
gauche n'a eu le pire président depuis
le début de la vème république qui juste
est un chef de parti qui a les 10 et se
comporte comme un chef de parti
aujourd'hui en se livrant en acceptant
avec la primaire à gauche il se livre
encore plus à la logique des partis mais
françois hollande un aveu de faiblesse
françois hollande cherche toujours la
petite combinaison qui va lui permettre
de se sauver il a été dix ans patron du
parti socialiste il a passé son temps à
ça et c'est sa vie c'est son
savoir-faire y pense à rien d'autre
qu'un salaire de marchés puisqu'il ya un
premier sondage qui était publié non
mais c'est l'instant et qui montre parmi
les sympathisants de gauche ils arrivent
en tête devant emmanuel macron devant
les oreilles de l'avoir d'abord le
critère pour savoir si ça marche c'est
l'état du pays avant tout au tout prend
d'état du pays je vous fais pas un
dessin et imaginer qu'il soit réélu
demain
vous croyez vraiment que ça sera un
critère de succès ainsi dans mes propres
aux amis ont dit de regarder
il a dit on fait des primaires est le
candidat des primaires a été élu ah oui
il faut voir ce qu'on sauf au vol
résultat pour moi le résultat c'est pas
l'élection le résultat c'est l'état du
pays en deux ans cinq à 35 ans après bon
je parie on abaisse un peu plus c'est
pathétique on abaisse un peu plus sa
fonction présidentielle
c'est soi françois hollande considère
que
les français ne veulent plus et il s'en
va soyez pour saisir encore une chance
et il se présente il est président de la
république
imaginez déjà ces problématiques pour un
ancien président de la république c'est
par le renouveau de la démocratie pensée
d'un rouleau de la démo le spectacle
réside non c'est pas de la démocratie la
démocratie c'est le peuple qui vote 1
c'est pas un petit morceau du peuple qui
essaient de confisquer une élection pour
le dit le premier ministre le ps est en
avance pour lui et bien sûr non
messieurs en avance encore une fois on a
vu d'ailleurs le résultat c'est
magnifique on a eu en lisant ça a été la
revanche je suis appelé la vieillesse et
philo sur le sur le parti socialiste
françois mitterrand
les notables socialistes on aa notables
socialistes qui est chef de parti qui
est chef de camp c'est magnifique le
résultat est extraordinaire même sens
quand on veut plus on sait c'est
extraordinaire parce que le sondage de
da c'est quand même que pour un
président sortant dans son propre camp
moins d'un tiers
moins d'un tiers de deux supporteurs
c'est quand même si même extraordinaire
comme comme résultat non c'est pas la
démocratie c'est le contraire de la
démocratie c'est une apparence de
démocratie qui confisque la démocratie
vous allez dire quelque chose sur
nicolas sarkozy
non je dis ça pour rien je devais nancy
avec une ancienne en faire maintenant de
la république
ils se trouvent obligés d'aller se
confronter avec ses anciens ministres
son ancien premier ministre 1
c'est son ancien plus fous sont enfermés
moi je fais pas campagne
maintenant je fais pas campagne contre
nicolas sarkozy je trouve un système
après la compétition est oui j'entends
la compétion parce que je peux pas
rester les bras croisés d'un système
prêts vous critiquez beaucoup vous avez
oui enfin mitterrand a fait le plein de
paradoxes
non c'est pas un paradoxe ça s'appelle
le hainaut et critique sur le site
dangereux chez moi donc j'ai chez moi je
vais faire un hall à genève espère
maintenant paradoxe non c'est non non
c'est un paradoxe
je vous rappelle l'exemple remarquable
de françois mitterrand qui écrit le coup
d'état permanent à propos de la
cinquième langue unique qui se présente
trois fois aux élections présidentielles
se finit bien donc dû éléments finis par
l'évaluation
voilà qui finit par être élu parce
qu'elle était une institution de bande s
france a toujours refusé les sens de
l'histoire mais et françois mitterrand
qui à n'importe quel
on pose la question quand il après son
élection lundi mais vous trouviez que
les institutions de la vème république
était dangereuse et qui répond
admirablement vous savez elle était
dangereuse avoir mois l'heureux deux
viendront après moi voilà alors c'est
donc les primes elles sont là je joue
c'est une règle qu'on a fixés très bien
je veux bien essayer de jouer le jeu
mais je les dis je leur dis tout de
suite si ces primaires sont verrouillés
par les parties au point qu'il n'est pas
possible d'y participer parce que le
système des notables entre eux soit des
notables est tellement prégnant que lui
paraissait impossible d'obtenir ces cds
parrainage de parlementaire et bien et
donc vous savez ce moment là j'irai
chercher dans toute la france les 500
signatures d'élus qui permettent de se
présenter s'est bien produit d'une
semaine que vous avez annoncé votre
candidature vous avez eu des soutiens
répondait combien parena vous répondrai
pas à vous le saurez le moment venu vous
avez commencé votre chat soit déjà au
moins oui j'ai commencé par la chasse
aux élus locaux gt500 on a parlé de
nicolas sarkozy je me suis très très
serein soit j'y arrive sans me sans
renoncer à aucune idée semble aplatir
devant tout le monde ça voilà au milieu
de toutes les pressions de toutes les
branches que vous pouvez imaginer ce
qu'il dit je ne désespère pas de le
convaincre mais on a manqué son propos d
alimenter le falher ne verrez vous lui
demanderez n'est que vous demanderez à
elle parle à propos de nicolas sarkozy
est coté à propos nicolas sarkozy le
sénateur jean baptiste lemoyne lui
demande de se déclarer désormais sans
trop patent dans les côtes
le 2 juillet a lieu le conseil national
des républicains à cette occasion là je
dirais il aura achevé la mise en marche
du parti
je pense que dès lors que le conseil
national du 2 juillet passé le plus
simple qui se déclarent le plus
rapidement possible mais y compris y
compris pour lui parce que ça lui
permettra justement de tordre le cou un
certain nombre de rumeurs et c'est sur
le mode il utilise le parti état mais au
demeurant prendre le parti s'était pas
non plus une dire une promenade de santé
parce que c'est aussi il a pris des
risques de ce conte de villa
jeudi les élections cantonales
régionales etc n'étaient pas jouer et
donc quelque part aujourd'hui
effectivement ça lui a procuré un petit
avantage on va dire le fait de pouvoir
tourner dans les faits d etc
mais en même temps il a aussi pris des
risques en parallèle alors c'est un
avantage pour le président des
républicains
deux d'être encore président jusqu'aux à
la fin je considère que c'est un
désavantage depuis le début d'être à la
tête de d'un parti politique dans tous
les reproches un conflit être revenu à
la tête non mais ça je pouvais avait
déconseillé vous deux relais je pense
comme président un ancien président de
la république ne devient pas chef de
parti il ne le fait qu'à son détriment
alors considéré que ça a permis de
sauver particulier explosé mais enfin il
a perdu des plumes dans cette histoire
oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui les hommes
politique négligent beaucoup trop la
dimension symbolique de la politique et
en particulier de la fonction président
sait ce qu'il doit se déclarer au plus
vite selon vous nicolas sarkozy moi j'ai
aucune foi commentaire à faire là-dessus
où celle-ci de vieil argument quand vous
êtes président de la république sortant
vous dire que vous vous confondez au
premier ministre confondez votre
fonction avec la campagne oui mais enfin
on va pas faire démissionner le
président de la république un an avant
l'élection
bon il est chef de parti à lui apporter
leur tire mon à lui de faire la part des
choses mais vous savez c'est pas parce
que vous pouvez utiliser les mois une
partie que vous êtes vous avez un énorme
avantage
avantage le seul avantage
mais c'est vrai pour tous les pour tous
les notables en présent ce sont les
fichiers les fichiers les adhérents à
qui on peut y arriver ou sympathisants
bref ça permet de comparer campagne ils
sont pas ici sont ils sont pas
disponibles pour tout le monde de la
ferme étatiques et non pas de fichier
really faites vous passer des coups de
téléphone
je fais comme je peux mais moi j'accepte
l'idée d'aller tout seul avec juste avec
les bonnes volontés qui vont se
manifester à la rencontre des français
et nous verrons bien si ce sont les
grosses machines partisane avec leurs
meetings dispendieux leur débauche de
moyens qui gagne où sont les yeux henri
guaino la franqui aux fonds non non non
non rien que leurs convictions et leurs
envies de il n'y a pas mal d'anciens
candidats pour beaucoup dans vie qui
viennent aussi des anciens proches de
nicolas sarkozy a dit mme morano
geoffroy didier faudrait voilà on n'y a
pas de club en club
est ce que font sincèrement vous ne
visez pas affaiblir alain juppé s'ils
l'emportent à primaire henri guaino
nous venons mais pensez toujours que un
homme politique ne peut pas ne pas avoir
d'arrière-pensées de calcul minable de
ce genre et bien non je n'ai pas
quelques minables de ce genre je suis en
désaccord avec alain juppé jeu tout le
monde le sait ça fait très longtemps je
continue de l'être mais ma candidature
n'a pas pour objet de favoriser l'un
contenant autant ni de me présenter
contre nicolas sarkozy ni contre
françois fillon je veux développer mes
idées il est clair que nous aurons des
débats et des oppositions avaient sur
l'icône du dock sur l'économie bien sûr
les connais gagner sur par exemple avec
alain juppé sur la société
multiculturelle nous aurons des
divergences sur l'europe ou alors on va
terminer sur une note culturelle et
politique en même temps avec le musée
des arts premiers un quai branly à marie
qui est devenu le musée jacques chirac
l'occasion en plein retour du débat sur
les valeurs d'ailleurs 1
ré initié par nicolas sarkozy d'autres
jours de se remémorer le message
universaliste dont étaient porteurs
l'ancien chef de l'état a écouté sa
fille claude
c'était sur public sénat dans l'émission
bibliothèque médicis
on a été élevés avec des quelques
fondamentaux et sans état c'est à dire
que c'est vraiment pour moi le message
de ce musée c'est vraiment un des
fondamentaux de l'éducation qui nous
aura transmises
c'est à dire au fond l'indivisibilité de
l'humanité le fait qu'on n'ait
absolument tous égaux et différents à la
fois mais tous égaux alors égalité des
hommes égalité des cultures alors les
gars nous le message chiraquien donc la
vision pacifié du monde comme le disait
donc sa fille pas de hiérarchie entre
les peuples et les cultures
est ce que cette vision entre en conflit
avec les débats actuels sur l'identité
française à l'époque sens on donne aux
mots d'abord il ya pas de culture sans
hiérarchie des valeurs
donc quand d'autres cultures ont une
hiérarchie des valeurs très différentes
bah il est clair qu'il ya des vous
établissez chacun établit lui même une
hiérarchie entre les cultures en
fonction de la hiérarchie des bailleurs
qui prévaut à l'intérieur de chacune
d'entre elles enfin je veux dire ce
débat n'est pas ça en allant lévriers à
l'universalité mais non tout n'est pas
égal ce n'est pas vrai tout n'est pas
relatif c'est que l'anthropologue banc
cela est une chose est une chose mais
parce que c'est parce que c'est son
métier d' essayer de regarder chaque
culture en elle même et pour sa propre
valeur mais sans les erreurs
enfin si vous voulez entendre plus de
rentrer propager une culture qui est pas
je pense qu'une supériorité de la
culture qui dépend anthropophage voilà
je pense que il ya ya
il ya une supériorité des cultures qui
sont fondés sur le sacrifice humain fans
sky au printemps des cultures qui ne
sont pas fondés sur le nom du fils
humains celles qui sont tournés sur les
sacrifices humains
il ya dans l'histoire je ne parle pas
que de la situation actuelle mais mais
c'est normal la question est de savoir
si on accepte l'autre dans sa différence
n'est pas de penser que l'autre ne peut
pas être différent de soir parker dans
soi et on peut avoir des préférences est
normal merci merci d'avoir été avec nous
en règle no mercy deborah merci à tous
bonsoir et la semaine prochaine notre
invité sur un michel sapin la semaine
prochaine